I want to tell you a joke. A Muslim
hosts a live stream with guests that
consist of a Trinitarian Christian, a
Jehovah's Witness, an LDS Mormon, and
other Muslims.
How you think it went?
>> [music]
[music]
>> Yes, and you can't derive a oneness of
being in the biblical text.
We absolutely can. I think you just was
>> can't.
He He could just show that with Isaiah 6
and John 12 and Acts 28. That That
wouldn't be a showing of oneness of
being. That wouldn't be a showing of
oneness of being. That That wouldn't be
showing a oneness of being. That would
be a showing a multiplicity of
personages.
Within what?
>> you think is being said when when God
Logic is identifying in John that Jesus
is the Yahweh
of the Old Testament? What do you What
do you think that's saying?
It's most definitely not saying that
they're the They're They're
>> No, what it's not saying. What is it
saying? It just means that they're all
They're both Yahweh, and the Bible says
that it's a divine [clears throat] name
that they all share. And if Jesus Christ
the No, it doesn't.
>> Father have that
It doesn't It doesn't say that the that
Yahweh is a divine name.
No, what you just said. You're saying
that it's just a divine name that they
all share. No, uh Yahweh is not just a
divine name, but it is the identity of
God in in which no one can be identified
as other than the most high God creator,
the one being.
I I get that, but Yahweh is a divine
name. Like they can share the same name.
Obviously, the the three separate
personages The three distinct personages
of Yahweh share that same title. Would
you agree with that or disagree with
>> In Nehemiah 9:6, it says, "You alone are
Yahweh."
So, can any Is Does this Can this name
be shared?
Yes. Um I I watched some of your I I
watched some of your debate with Jacob
Hanson.
Um and it was a pretty solid debate from
both of you. Um but one of the things
that I don't think you really understood
was the whole court
um the court analogy that he brought up.
Are you familiar with that or Yeah, can
Yeah, can Can one of the judges that's
part of the court claim to be the full
court
themself?
Yes, they can. No, they cannot. That
would be a Would Okay, if they claim
that, cuz you know, yes, that that can't
They can't utter their mouths to say
that.
Um if they said that, would they be
telling the truth that they themselves
are the court?
Yes. Brother, you are so
You are so You're so You're so
dishonest.
>> No, I'm not. No, they don't say that,
and they can't say that, and they would
be lying if they If If you had a If you
had a court made up of three judges,
and one of the judges steps out and
says, "I am the court." That would be
incorrect, wouldn't it?
If they have the same purpose and and um
whatever the court case is, yes, they
can. What if they did What What if the
judge disagrees with the the other two
or one of them disagrees?
Can one of them claim to
>> The Godhead would be unified in purpose.
>> Can Can one of them claim to be the full
court themself?
Yeah. Would it be accurate?
Yeah. Okay. And so, this And this is
where
>> They're not dependent They're not
dependent on each other like Brother,
it's it's okay. This This is This is
where the dishonesty of the argument
comes.
I think that any any thinking human
being understands that if you're If you
have a court with three judges made up
of three judges, not one of the judges
can claim to be the court themselves.
They, along with the others, make up the
court. If they were to fix their mouths
to say that, they would be inaccurate.
They can say that they're part of the
court, that they are a judge in the
court, but they themselves cannot claim
to be the court in full themselves,
which is what we see with the Father,
Son, and Spirit. They don't claim to be
part of Yahweh. They claim to be Yahweh.
They are identified as Yahweh. The
judges wouldn't be identified as the
court. That's horrible. It doesn't work.
That's That's Let's Let's read Let's
read Deuteronomy 6:4. It said, "Hear, O
Israel, Hold on, Mr.
>> Yahweh is our God, Yahweh is one."
>> Wait. Wait. Wait. Wait. Wait. Wait.
Wait. Wait. Let's Let's give the mic to
Michael for a little bit, please. Let
Michael have some words in there.
Based on um what God Logic just said
about the court, let's take a look at
real quick Daniel, chapter 7.
Let's take a look at Daniel, chapter 7,
about the court.
Now, I'mma ask a a pre-question.
Where was Jesus
when the court took its seat in Daniel,
chapter 7,
verse
9 and 10?
Where would Where would Jesus have been
when the court took its seat?
That's a good one.
Since he Since all of the Since what
he's saying is all three of them
All three of them is the court. Where
would Jesus have been?
>> not saying that. I never said That's not
my analogy, brother. That's Latter-Day's
analogy. I don't agree with that
analogy.
But you're saying But you are saying But
here's the problem. You are saying
that Jesus is Jehovah. That's what
you've said. You said he's Yahweh.
Excuse me, I use your term. You said he
is Yahweh.
>> with using Jehovah. That's cool.
So, and and there's You're saying
there's one God.
Yeah.
>> One divine One divine being.
Right. Now, somebody in the audience
said, "Is God Logic oneness now?"
I thought it was an appropriate
question.
But How's that an appropriate question?
That's just a straw man.
It's not a straw man. Yeah, if I say
that If I say the Father, Son, and
Spirit are three distinct persons, you
cannot ask if I'm oneness.
Yeah, but we see God is a title.
Right? Sure.
>> God is also can be used
>> But Yeah, it can be The term God can
also be referring to a divine being.
Correct? Yeah.
Okay. So, now,
we need to clarify very clearly
is when it refers to the Father,
what is it saying when it says the
Father
is the is God? Is it saying he's just a
divine being?
Or are we saying Or is the Bible saying
that he is the ultimate judge? But
before we Before we move to that, cuz I
think that's a fair question. Do you
agree, though, that
uh Do you agree with Latter-Day's
analogy that Jesus, the Father, and the
Spirit would be just three judges that's
part of a court as Jehovah, or do you
think that that analogy is inadequate?
No, I don't I don't agree with it that
understanding at all. The equal judges?
Cuz they wouldn't be equal. Well, I
don't You see, my thing about Latter-Day
Saints, I didn't know you guys was
Trinitarian. They're not. They're
polytheists. Yeah, we're not. Right.
So, if you're making If you're making
the Holy Spirit a person,
He's not a person. Right. So, then then
the Holy Spirit is not judging anything.
>> In LDS theology, you literally believe
that the Holy Spirit is a person. You
believe he's another god.
>> said he wasn't. I'm not arguing
>> in the being, but he
I think Michael is a Jehovah's Witness
or or Am I right?
>> Yeah, Michael's a Jehovah's Witness. MJ
and Latter-Day are both uh Mormons or
Latter-Day Saints.
>> Right.
So, [laughter] so, so we have to say
that too.
Okay, so Yeah, we all get along.
I'm only one, brother. I'm just quiet,
listening to y'all, trying to figure
[laughter] out your own And we pray to
the Father in Jesus' name. I just want
to say
that.
No, you're No, you're You're in this,
too, man.
Host, you're in this, too.
>> quick, I just Let me just cover
[laughter] this. Brother, I'm just
trying to I'm just trying to bring
peace. You know what? I'm just trying to
bring peace, brother.
>> I bet. We love you, Michael.
>> So, I just want to I just want to cover
this. In Daniel, chapter
>> I appreciate it, brother.
>> Daniel In Daniel, chapter 7,
>> "And there's more people than God Logic
up here with the gifters."
Okay?
Okay, and you don't have to be like
that. [laughter]
What's What's with the contention?
>> I love you, MJ. Yeah, what's What's with
that, MJ? [laughter]
Oh, you see that like almost 5K. We're
like
5K. MJ, be careful. God's word Go on. Go
on. Go on. Sorry, brother. Sorry.
God's word is not for pedaling, so don't
don't be envious of that. But
>> No, I I was joking. I really don't care
that much.
>> In In Daniel In Daniel, chapter 7, Jesus
Christ wasn't there. When it said there
in the verse number 10,
when it said in verse number 10, when
the Ancient of Days sat down, his
clothes His clothing, his hair,
everything speaking of him. It then said
in verse 10, "The court took its seat,
and books were opened." Now, where was
Jesus? Well, he wasn't there at that
moment. Why? Because in verse 13, we see
Daniel saying, "I kept watching." So, he
continued to watch. And then he said,
"And look, visions of the night, in the
clouds of heaven, someone like a son of
man was coming.
And he gained access to the Ancient of
Days, and they brought him up close
before that one." So, when the court
took its seat, did Jesus Christ take its
seat with the court? No, the court
didn't He took his seat with the Ancient
of Days.
All right. So, but when the when the
Ancient of Days took its seat,
it said the court took its seat. Was
Jesus there? Not with the court. He came
after and then sat and sat with the
Ancient of Days.
>> The simple answer was he was not there.
He He He sat with the Ancient of Days,
Michael. So, what What's the issue?
>> He was not there.
That's the point. Okay, and then he came
and sat with the Ancient of Days. So,
what's the argument?
>> [laughter]
[laughter]
>> That's fine. You know why? You're
proving he's Jehovah, by the way.
>> [laughter]
>> That's fine. That's fine, too. Cuz he
neither did sit down.
But did Jesus Christ sit down alone?
He sat with the Ancient of Days. I know.
No, no, no. You're not understanding
[laughter] my question. You're not
understanding my question.
Did Jesus Christ sit down alone on that
throne? No, he sat down with the Ancient
of Days. He only sat down with the
Ancient of Days? Yeah, that's who he was
next to. You say it again. He only sat
down with the Ancient of Days. He sat
down with the Ancient of Days. When it
says thrones were placed in verse nine,
the Ancient of
Hold on, let me finish. When it says in
verse nine that the Ancient of There
were thrones, plural, thrones placed and
the Ancient of Days took his seat,
then you got the court that then sits
down and then you have the Son of Man
who comes and sits with the Ancient of
Days. Okay, so who's the court? Here's
the question. Who is the court? It'll be
the host of heaven, I don't know,
probably.
The who?
The host of heaven.
The host of heaven, meaning who? The The
other angels?
>> The Not the other angels, but the
angels.
The angels. Okay, you don't like the
other angels. Okay, no No, cuz I see
what you're trying to do there. No no
problem. No [laughter] problem.
No problem. So,
Jesus did not sit down on the throne
alone with Yahweh, did he?
Yes, he's the only one who sits on the
throne with Yahweh.
>> Okay, so let's read So, let's read
Revelation chapter Since he says yes,
let's see what Jesus says in Revelation
chapter three Uh verse 21. Okay. Now,
listen to what it says. Now, this was a
vision of the far further future. Mhm.
Now, before you speak, be careful cuz
I'm not trying to embarrass you. Yeah,
this is this
>> not trying to catch you. It's okay.
>> trying to catch you. Go ahead. I'm just
This is just going to
This is going to be She said yes, it was
only him. It's not going to be It's not
going to be tough for me. It's going to
be tough for you.
>> I know.
So, here's what Jesus said. Here's what
Jesus said. Mhm.
>> [clears throat]
>> To the one who conquers,
I will grant to sit down with me on my
throne,
just as I've have sat down with my
father on his throne. So, will Jesus
Christ and only his father be sitting on
that throne? Yes, cuz these are two
different contexts. Now, if we go with
you, let me go with you for a second.
That you believe So, so you believe that
the believers
will be sitting on the throne of
Jehovah, on Jehovah's throne?
Whatever throne they sitting on.
So, is that a yes?
That's a yes. Okay. And so, that means
that the that the these believers will
be sitting on high, is that right?
What do you mean by sitting on high? I
don't know what you're what you're
referring to.
>> Jehovah's throne is on high, is it not?
No, he can't be sitting No, they cannot
be sitting on high.
You see?
>> [laughter]
>> You see I I explain why. You're starting
to see how.
You're starting to see how.
Remember be Be careful with your words
cuz I don't want you to embarrass
yourself.
>> with your words because be careful with
your words. Jesus, excuse me. Hebrews
chapter one, verse three, says that
Jesus sat down at the right hand of the
majesty on high. Is he the majesty on
high? Yes or no? Uh see, that's speaking
of the father in that verse. Hold on,
just really quick.
Let
>> Let me finish answering you cuz you just
dodged the question that I asked you.
So, I'm going to answer
I'm going to answer you this question
and then we're going to go back to your
argument. Yep, we're going to go back to
your argument. So, in this context, now
the majesty on high is being referred is
a reference to the father specifically,
but both he and the father are sitting
on high. Now, with your
argument, you went to Revelation 3 to
try to argue that Jesus doesn't sit on
his throne alone, but he also with the
believers sits on not only his throne,
but on his father's throne, on Jehovah's
throne. So, the question is then,
is Jehovah's throne on high?
Uh Jehovah's throne Jehovah is throne is
that he is the majesty on high. Now, Is
Jehovah's throne on high, Michael?
No, Jehovah is the majesty on high. No,
that's His throne ain't on high. His
throne is not on high? There's no such
No, there's no such thing as throne
Throne is on high. Okay, so
Hold on, let me I want to give you a
verse. I I brought I asked this question
to give a verse cuz I You got your
verse? Let me get my verse.
>> Michael, Michael, let him let him give
you a verse. Michael, let him give you a
verse.
So, we're going to go to Psalm.
I believe it's going to be Psalm 113.
But let me just double-check Jehovah
sits on high. We we understand that.
>> Okay, so you understand that it says
Jehovah sits on high.
So, so according to the Psalms,
Jehovah's throne is on high, correct?
Jehovah sits on high. Sits on what?
The clouds?
No, brother. A throne Okay, let me help
you out.
Throne [clears throat] represents
authority. I agree. Right? Mhm. Okay.
So, so do you think that this is
figurative or does he actually have a
throne he sits on?
Wait a minute. Wait a minute.
Be careful, brother. I'm trying to help
you before Yeah, actually yeah, try to
help me. Try to help me.
>> [laughter]
>> you said you agree that a throne
represents authority, right?
>> Yeah, in certain context. And then you
have the then actual throne.
Okay. So, that's my question. Does Does
Jehovah have an actual throne or not,
bro?
We don't know. I'm not in heaven, so we
can't say.
>> You don't know? You just read in Daniel
7 that that the Ancient of Days sat down
on his throne, right? You asked You
asked a question about something you nor
I absolutely know. Now, we can go with
that says. No, Michael. You brought
Michael, you brought Daniel 7
and you brought up where Let's just I'm
going to read it for you again. It says,
you brought this, not me.
As I looked, thrones were placed
and the Ancient of Days took his seat.
Is this actually happening or is this
some type of game that Daniel's playing
with us?
Daniel's having a vision, so we can't
tell anyone that this is actually
happening. It's a vision A vision?
>> is granting Daniel. So, wait, in In
visions, things don't actually happen?
If it's a vision, how could it actually
be happening? So, when when John has a
vision and he sees No, but let's
actually do this. In the same vision
where it says that the Son of Man is
given glory and honor and and a kingdom,
does this actually happen or is this
like just
>> of Man is absolutely given glory and
honor and kingdom. But this is But this
is a vision.
So, what? It's a vision of the future,
right?
>> Exa- That's my point. Okay. So, a vision
is a vision is revelation of things to
come, something actually happening,
right? So, in things to come, he's
seeing he's seeing in the in the
heavenly in the heavenly realm, he sees
that thrones are placed and the Ancient
of Days takes his seat.
So, the Ancient of Days has a throne
that he sits on, right?
That's correct. Okay. That's what what
the text says. Awesome. And so, we know
where his throne is. Is he sits on high
specifically, correct?
No, he's the majesty on high. So, yes,
Jehovah's sitting on high. Okay. Very
good. So, he sits on high.
So,
now, we we you and I agree that
depending on the context, thrones can be
figurative for authority, right?
Authority or position, you know.
So, when it says that the saints
Hold on, before you finish. Hold on,
before you finish.
Uh to the host, I'm allowing him to go
through everything. I want you to allow
me to
do the same thing. No, no, no. You ain't
got to As long as he is willing
to allow me On you?
Yeah.
>> [clears throat]
>> I'm He's the one talking, not me.
Yeah, yeah, God logic.
Nobody talk to Michael. Go ahead,
Michael. Okay. No, no, God logic was
finished.
>> [laughter]
>> Okay. So, we know that Yahweh, Jehovah,
sits on high. His throne is placed and
he sits on high.
You brought us Revelation 3 where Jesus
says that he will he and will he'll
allow the believers to also sit on
Jehovah's throne,
right? Is this saying that the saints
are going to sit on high on Jehovah's
actual throne or is this figurative for
Jehovah giving them authority
and them operating in in in his
authority?
That's that's what it's saying. They're
given They're given authority just as
Jesus Christ is given authority. Is that
correct? Sure.
So, yes.
Brother, I'm the one who helped you make
this distinction. My My point is
Yes, yes, I'm the one who helped you.
My My point is
I I did.
I I did. I See, see, this is this is
this is this is how I This is how we got
to You got to be careful with your
words. Michael, hold on, hold on. Yeah,
yeah, hold on. Hold on, hold on.
Michael, Michael, let's hear what he's
trying to give you the point because he
was about to say my point is. Let Let
Let us see what his point is.
Okay. He's backtracking. No No worries.
Just as Christ was given authority as
the humble servant, so the saints are
also given authority. No problem. But
that's different from Jesus sitting on
high with the Ancient of Days, with
Jehovah, which the scripture says that
there's no one who sits on high like
Jehovah. And yet Jesus does. So, this is
where we're at. Either Jesus is Jehovah
who sits on high and so Jehovah's
multi-personal or you have a
contradiction and you have multiple
persons that sit on high when the Bible
says no one else can. Okay. So, now, do
me a favor. Can you show me
where only Jesus Christ is the one who
sits on high with Jehovah? Well, you
would have to show me where anyone else
does. So, we have we have we have Daniel
7 Just really quick. We have Daniel 7
who says that the the Son of Man is
sitting with the Ancient of Days which
is on high. You have Hebrews 1:3 that
says that Jesus sat on high with the
majesty. So, can you show me anybody
else who sits on high outside of Christ
and the Father? For number one, Daniel 7
Daniel 7 never says that Jesus Christ
sits on high. Verse 14 says to him was
given rulership uh majesty, the throne,
and so forth and so on. It never said he
sat on high.
So, that's something you inserted that
he sits on high. Nonetheless, we know
that he was given authority by the one
who can give him authority. So, let me
ask you a very simple question. You
didn't answer the question that you that
you proposed.
>> I answered. You're not listening. Let me
say it again.
Daniel chapter 7:14
>> have to repeat yourself. That's not what
I asked about.
>> I didn't You said you you said I didn't
answer the question, so I'm going to say
it again.
>> remember what the question was, Michael?
Did I cut you off?
But do you remember what the question
was? You said that Jesus Christ
>> was. You said listen to me. You ain't
listening. You made a statement. I
respond to the things you say, not
everything you ask.
>> [laughter]
>> You said
You said
and correct me if I'm wrong. Listen, I'm
straight up what I say. I respond to the
things you say.
>> I say something quick, Michael? Is that
okay if I say something quick? Would you
like him maybe repeat his question so
you can hear it? He can ask it again,
but I'm going to respond to what he
said. Yeah, yeah. So, can you show me
anywhere where someone other than Jesus
sits on high?
Okay. So, now I'm going to ask that
question, but let me let me say this
again.
There's no scripture. So, you the
question you asked was
the scripture said that Jesus sits on
high.
Where does the scripture say that Jesus
sits on high? Hebrews 1:3. You're the
one who brought it up. Hebrews 1:3 does
not say Jesus Christ sits on high. It
literally says he sits on high. No, it
does not. It said he sat down at the
right hand of the majesty on high. We
know
>> Oh.
Excuse me. Excuse me. You talked.
Now, let me go. Now,
uh he sits down at the right hand of the
majesty on high. You agree
>> So, where is he sitting?
>> Can I Brother, host, can you can you
pause him? What do you mean this is a
Yeah, God God logic. God logic. Let him
Let him Let him say his words. Let him
say his words.
>> he's nervous now. Yeah, God logic.
Now, I'm going to show you Why are we
nervous? I don't get it.
Exactly.
>> Pay attention, everybody. It's just It's
just bad rhetoric.
Okay, brother. Well, if it's bad
rhetoric, listen to
>> Hold on. Hold on. I want to hear it.
Now, listen. God logic agreed that Jesus
Christ was given authority
by the one who was able to give it to
him. Therefore, the person who is able
to give him the authority is the one who
can take it from him. Therefore, he can
never be sitting as the majesty on high.
But to answer his question, let's read
First Chronicles chapter 29
verse 23 speaking of King David. Very
important that we listen to this. Here's
what the Bible says.
Um David and Solomon, it said this. Hey,
Michael, just before you read it, right?
Mhm. You said he's going to take away
from him in Hebrew 1
that that seating was given to him is
forever and ever.
No one will take it away from him. We We
We going to see how he That's a Muslim,
by the way, correcting a Jehovah's
Witness. That's beautiful. And we will I
don't know. He ain't no damn Muslim.
He's in a Muslim? MJ is is a Muslim,
isn't he? Hello. Hello, can I finish? MJ
is a Muslim. I spoke to him the other
day.
No, he's a kafir, bro.
>> [laughter]
>> Hey, shut up. No,
he was kicked out a long time ago.
I'm kidding. I'm kidding.
>> [laughter]
>> You finished?
I thought this I thought this was a
conversation, not like a a monologue.
>> on, brother. We No, I I Yeah, that's
what I was kind of hoping for, and it
kind of turned into a debate at some
point. I don't know why
>> Yeah. I I I engaged with you with a
finish? I engaged with you. I didn't
just I didn't just talk for 3 minutes
straight. Can I finish?
Can I Cuz you brought up cuz you brought
up that he injected a few words, right?
You injected word, right? That he can
also take it away which is wrong.
In in in Hebrew 1, it says that throne
is given for him forever and ever. He's
everlasting throne. Can I finish?
Can I finish? Can Can we engage with
what you're saying, bro? You're just
going on and on.
>> Then you can engage after I finish.
Brother, if you're not nervous, just be
quiet. Host, you got to you got to let
us know like cuz he he's turning this
into a monologue and not a dialogue.
Like I don't I'm reading out the
scripture for you. Can I finish? Can I
read the scripture, please? Yeah, just
do it. Is this the last one you got?
No, no. I'm going to show you I'm going
to show you what So, you Oh my gosh. Do
you know how long I've waited for this?
Bro, I Yeah, after you read this verse,
I'm going to engage with what you're
saying, dude. We're going to actually
talk. I'm not going to let you just
waffle on.
>> to read the verse. I'm going to read the
verse, and then I'm going to ask you a
question. Is that okay? Yes or no? No,
because you didn't answer mine.
I'm about to answer your question. So,
after I answer your question,
>> even know what my question is.
Can I after I answer your question, can
I read the verse and ask you a question?
>> You can read the verse now, and then
let's again into the dialogue.
Can I ask you a question?
>> You'll ask the question after we engage
with what I asked you earlier. No, no,
no, no. I'm I'm I'm about to answer your
question as to who Can we do rock,
paper, scissors, or something? This is
crazy.
>> I'm Look, read your verse, Michael.
You're wasting time, dude.
>> No, no, no. Hold on. Hold on, brother.
Oh my goodness. This isn't a Jehovah's
Witness live where you can just Yes or
no? Read your verse. Read your verse so
we can talk.
>> to answer your question about who sits
on high according to what you're saying.
Who else sits
>> going to have we're going to have a
dialogue on that. And then I would like
to ask you a question if you're not
afraid.
>> Go read the verse and tell me if
somebody else sits on high. Listen to me
very
If I can't ask your question, you can't
I will never answer any of yours. Can
you just go to the verse where you're
about to show me where somebody other
than Jesus sits on high?
Why Excuse me. Why can I You asked me a
question, but I can't
>> Oh, Michael, just get to it, bro. Just
read the verse.
>> worrying about this. Can you read it
just for you?
All right. So, I'm going to read this
question. I'm going to read the
scripture, then I'm going to ask him a
question. If he's not afraid.
Sure, just read it. Read it to her.
Now, it
It says here in uh
First Chronicles 29:23
And Solomon
sat down on Jehovah's throne
as king in place of David his father.
And he was successful on the Israelite
and all the Israelites were obedient to
him.
Now, my question is
whose throne
was Jesus Christ given?
Okay, thank you. So, now notice the
notice the segue and the red herring.
This has nothing to do with what we're
asking. Back to Hebrews 1:3. It says
here It says here Excuse me.
You said You said You said that you were
going to answer my question, and you
didn't.
I asked you a question.
>> Instead of Instead of trying to answer
my question, what you did was deflect
yet again, and now you're interrupting
me. You spoke for 5 minutes
uninterrupted. You spoke for 5 minutes
uninterrupted. So, go ahead and relax
now.
Go ahead and relax now. This dude said
that he was going to answer our question
and never did.
Never did. Hey, can we move on? Yeah.
That was boring.
If you if you cannot, be quiet and uh
today we're just monitoring things. If
you can't keep up
If you can't let other people speak, you
have to go, buddy.
I just want to make this last this like
30-second point here.
He He was very dishonest with the text.
Like we can all like see it for
ourselves. It literally says in Hebrews
1:3,
He is the radiance of the glory of God
and the exact imprint of his nature, and
he upholds the universe by the word of
his power. After making purification for
sins, he sat down at the right hand of
the majesty. Where? On high.
He sat on high next to the majesty.
And he tried to say that Jesus does It
doesn't say Jesus sat on high. What an
absolute liar, bro.
I I I don't think he was tracking that
you weren't inserting into the text that
Jehovah's throne is on high in Daniel 7,
but you guys did
uh establish that Psalms identifies that
Jehovah's throne is on high. So, when
the when the text says he sits down sits
down next to Jehovah,
we don't have to make like it's not a
leap. It's not eisegesis. It's It's just
taking in the whole text of scripture.
So, I I don't think he I don't think he
addressed that. I think he failed to
kind of realize that.
Yeah, that's that's a lot of the
problems when it comes to this.
>> your heifer.
With MJ?
So,
so so the Bible clearly teaches that the
Trinity is there. We haven't heard any
good objections just yet, but more more
proof. So, God logic, can I ask you a
question?
Sure, what's your religion?
Uh I'm also LDS. Nice to meet you,
Avery. Nice to meet you, too.
Hey, can you define the Trinity for me?
Is it beings, persons? How many of them?
One divine being who consists of three
distinct persons.
Perfect. Perfect.
So,
that's called consubstantiality, right?
Same substances? Yeah.
Right. So, where is that found in the
Bible?
Uh all throughout. And Yahweh is the one
creator
um who created all by himself.
Um he's the
uh
the eternal God from everlasting to
everlasting.
Um infinite,
all-knowing, all-powerful being.
And this same being Those are great
descriptors, but can you provide a verse
that says
how he's consubstantial?
I I feel like I just How did How did
what I say not establish that? Can you
provide a verse in the Bible that
establishes that? That establishes what?
That establishes that he's a
consubstantial being made up of three
persons. That there's three distinct
persons that share the one nature, one
essence as Yahweh?
That they're one being.
He's He's appealing to an explicit
word-concept fallacy. Is that what it
is? You need it You need it like
verbatim?
I just need to know where it says that.
Are you asking Are you asking verbatim
because I cuz I said this? I said that
the Bible teaches all over the place
that there's one God and one divine
essence.
But if you if you could let me finish,
maybe you can hear what I'm saying and
then maybe you can
>> asked me a question. No, I was actually
speaking. Like I was trying to help you
out. So, if you just let me speak, you
might be able to hear me and maybe we
have a some understanding. Is that cool?
Yeah, brother here David the What's your
name? Devon Davin, whatever your name
is. You got to listen to people let
people finish their point, brother.
I'm sure.
So, the Bible teaches that there's one
God, one divine essence, Yahweh I
specifically. And Yahweh is identified
as three distinct persons. So, we see
that there are three persons who are all
identified as the one Yahweh, the
creator of heaven and earth who is
everlasting.
Um,
and [clears throat] there's no one
outside of the Father, Son, and Holy
Spirit who's identified as as Yahweh.
And what verse describe
What verse
>> What verse what? Cuz he cut out for me.
>> 1:1.
Yeah Yeah, what biblical verse would
describe that? You got Deuteronomy
chapter 6 verse 4. You have that says
that Yahweh is one. You have uh
John as the brother said John 1 that
identifies the word is God as well and
he was with some another person who's
identified as God. And you have the
spirit who proceeds from the Father.
In John 15.
>> Can you say how it is one what that word
means? One essence, one being.
That's what that word means is one
essence. That's what it's referring to.
So, when it says that Jesus wants
God Father and Jesus Christ to be one
and the disciples to be one with him, do
you hold that?
Do you think that means the same thing?
We Contextually, that's talking about
ministry work. So, that's one in purpose
contextually.
>> you looked at the Greek and the Hebrew
for those words?
Uh, yeah, I have. I don't know them off
the top of my head. I don't know how
that changes anything what I said.
So,
the one in Hebrew, right, is ehad.
Do you think that denotes
consubstantiality or unity? Depends on
the context.
In Deuteronomy 6:4 with that context,
it's specifically saying one being.
In Deuteronomy 6:4, it's saying one
being.
>> Yeah, so so all through through in
Deuteronomy 6, it is talking about
Yahweh in the singular and then with the
Shema says "Hear O Israel, Yahweh is our
God, Yahweh is one." Where they've only
been referring to Yahweh in the singular
form. Contextually, it wouldn't make any
sense for ehad to suddenly mean one in
purpose.
So, instead of it actually explicitly
saying that they are a consubstantial
being three persons.
>> It doesn't have to explicitly say it for
it to be true.
But this was too God logic. I don't know
why I don't like it.
>> I know, but why are you guys responding
if he's talking to God logic? This is
going to take so much longer. They're
They're allowed to respond to me. They
They have good good responses. They can
chime in.
Yeah, I do want to get Avery's position
on this cuz it doesn't seem like he
like
I don't know. When I was watching the
debate with Jacob Hansen, I wasn't sure
if you understood the Trinity of the
doctrine cuz it seemed like you were
going into other belief systems that are
not Trinitarian such as like partialism
and modalism.
So, I was trying to see if you
understood what consubstantiality was.
Wait Wait When did I say When did I
advocate partialism or modalism?
Um, there was a few parts where you were
saying how to describe the Trinity
and it didn't sound like Trinitarianism,
so I was confused. That's why
>> Like what Like Like what part?
>> Is he a Trinitarian or is he actually
modalist? Like what part? Like what what
did I say that it that implied
partialism or even modalism?
Uh
Yeah, to be fair, I I couldn't remember
exactly which part, but there were a few
parts where it was like, "Wait, is that
Trinitarianism?" Yeah, every everything
that I everything that
>> should be more prepared and be more
specific. That's my bad.
>> Every everything on my on my end of my
end of the debate was a description of
the Trinity, not partialism or modalism.
I was very clear in that debate.
I'll have to be more specific so I can
really hone in on it better, but It's
okay. Um
So, Devon again, remember that the topic
of the debate that they had was is the
God of the Bible a Trinity?
>> debate, though.
>> [snorts]
>> I'm sorry.
>> This wasn't a debate. When God logic
came up, there was like three of us.
>> No, no.
MJ, he's talking He's talking about a
debate that I had.
>> I'm I'm talking about with Jacob Hansen
with with what Devon was referring to.
Uh, the topic was Is the Is the God of
the Bible a Trinity?
>> And God logic uh concentrated on pulling
passages that the concept of the Trinity
is very obviously communicated. If
you're appealing to an explicit
word-concept fallacy or an explicit
verbatim uh statement, you're probably
not going to find it because theology
works on philosophical terms and
biblical concepts. That's how all
theology works.
Avery, would you say that the one mind
of God is biblical?
You did You did make that statement that
God only has one mind.
Yeah.
Isn't that deemed as like a heresy? That
God has one mind? No, there's one divine
mind.
>> Yeah.
Interesting.
Yeah. So So, my question is So, my
question is My question is
the Trinity is not a biblical because
it's a man-made word. So, why would you
follow a man-made word?
Well, the Trinity is a biblical concept.
So, if you're taking man and how they
reason with the scripture and they throw
a name on it, there's no problem with
that. It's like like for example,
uh omnipresent or omni- omnipotence. The
word omnipotence is man-made. What's up,
Jay? It's It's uh The problem is the new
word
>> It's taking a concept. Hold on really
quick. It's The word
>> I know. I know what you're going to go
with this, Jay. Yeah, he's going to ask
us where's tawhid Where's tawhid in the
in the Quran. Then we say
>> Yeah, I know. Where's tawhid? [laughter]
Yeah, I know. Yeah, so I I take it back.
I'm I'm going to swallow my words.
>> [laughter]
>> We still love you, man.
>> Go beat yourself, sir.
>> [clears throat]
>> I'm trying to uh I'm going to let you
have your turn. I'm I'm trying to act
like I know something. Leave me alone,
man.
>> [laughter]
>> Silly.
>> [snorts]
>> Yeah, so the Trinity's biblical, guys.
Are we all in agreement now?
>> No.
No.
I mean, I still I mean, I haven't heard
nobody to defend it like it's not a
biblical. I mean, according to what I'm
hearing, I mean
>> every time we come up with the position
that we speaking and they prove that it
exists, so y'all took the L. I'm sorry.
Hey.
Oh, no.
Uh-uh. I mean, like
>> what? With that, I'mma go ahead and take
my dub and I'mma go ahead and sit down
somewhere.
>> later, dude. Guys, the Trinity is
undefeated.
As you see. There's no defense. The LDS
heretics, Jehovah's Witness heretics,
Muslims, they all flop when attacking
the Trinity because it's rooted in
biblical truth. It's undefeated. What's
the
Only thing we do around here is we just
read, man.
That's all it takes.
What's the only thing we do?
We just read. We just read. We just
read. This what your book said. Don't
blame me.
We just read. We just read. This what
your book said. Don't blame me. [music]
Hey, here's a challenge for you. Open up
your book. Can you read it and explain
to us how Allah ain't a crook? I see
[music] you can make it pretty, but it's
not about the look because the words and
what they mean is why you always getting
cooked. Easy mode. We just reading and
relaying [music] what was said. You
don't even read your